philippe est enchantée il peut
dorénavant s'entraîner dans un
planchodrome tout neuf chez lui mais je
trouve ça incroyable parce que montréal
ont jamais eu dépôt des ces niveaux là
quand jambon les jeunes grandir là
dedans je m'attends à ce que la
prochaine génération soit est vraiment
bon dont - je savais qu'un à pratiquer
la dans l'eau je sais qu'elle est
capable d'en prendre pas mal cet immense
bol conçu pour la pratique de la
discipline olympique par querrey a été
construit grâce à un partenariat entre
la compagnie american funds et la régie
des installations olympiques
un investissement de l'ordre de 5
millions de dollars dans son ensemble
qui répond à un besoin criant à travers
le canada sur montréal et gérer c'est
une des seules grandes villes qui a
raconté processeur similaire donc là on
à la mairie
bobby gasquet au prêche pour sa paroisse
ce montréalais établi en californie aux
commandes de ce championnat
international de planche à roulettes
nourrit de grandes ambitions pour les
adeptes de ce sport
l'important c'est de laisser derrière un
pack pour que la communauté peut que
bénéficier de développer ses parts et
d'inspirer les nouvelles générations
[Applaudissements]
oui avec les pantalons emballant d'armes
in montreal and dine al ani guglia
pourrait être la première canadienne à
prendre part à une épreuve de planche à
roulettes rejetons chiot sur le parcours
aménagé juste à côté du nouveau
planchodrome lm prodiguer des conseils à
donner des preuves mais ça semble
vraiment facile pour toi faire ce sport
pourquoi c'est facile avec je donne
parce que tellement de talent laissons
donc jaden développer son talent inné et
les experts nous en mettre plein la vue
jean françois poirier radio-canada
mourir